j'ai eu la chance inouïe de rencontrer
les inconnus pour de vrai franchement on
n'est pas issu de la même génération
mais ça c'est pas ressenti faut donc moi
je l'appelle norman et je fais des
vidéos donc sur internet
oui l'internet l'on reconnaît l'internet
même en fait si là il assure alors dit
alors l'ordinateur je devais leur
proposer une idée de sketches on aurait
peut-être pu faire ensemble et j'avais
j'avais trop peur que les mecs ils
réagissent comme ça même si ému il est
où le gag est ce qu'on rigole mais aussi
moins trente ans de métier j'ai jamais
savouré ce qu'on rigole là dedans ça ce
que tu veux qu'on rigole là dessus pour
moi j'étais moi j'étais un peu timide
jouets qu'ils étaient en train de me
juger
et j'avais trop peur de faire une gaffe
ou dire un truc de travers et et
finalement c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé et moi dans le sketch je pourrais
faire les blagues de jeunes et vous
pourriez faire les blacks de laisser les
blacks de deux jeunes de l'époque un peu
hippie des bacs de hippies
ils doivent me détester du coup au fil
du rendez-vous il m'a fait comprendre
qu'ils étaient pas trop trop intéressé
par mon sketch du moins c'est ce que
j'en ai déduit vu leur attitude pendant
que leur parler et un moment dans le
sketch on aurait carrément pu jouer tous
les quatre genres des télétubbies comme
ça et la fin pourrait chanter
isabelle a les yeux bleus mais version
dub step dans l'espace voilà ça vous
plaît ouais super est super bonne idée
mais voilà enfin en bas on se rappelle
d'accord vous avez pas mon numéro
pas grave on t'a pas quand même bon moi
je crois qu'il me qui me rappelleront
jamais normal alors viens de l'internet
maintenant que tu apprennes pour nous un
et on a découvert twitter
on n'arrête pas de pourquoi on a vu des
vidéos la vidéo de super branché on
adore [ __ ] on peut peut-être faire une
petite vidéo la haye
et qu'est-ce que je dois dire alors
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je dise un
texte de valoriser une vidéo chez toi
mais je vais pas forcément avec toi
ouais voilà voilà
on voit conscience comme ça mais toi là
ça va te fais ça c'est mieux oui si tu
peux aller en bus d'ailleurs juste soit
chaud ça marche ouais super salué ces
les uns on va faire une vidéo sur
youtube parce que nous on est vachement
les avec la wii
[Musique]
oui ça peut tourner très à l'aise avec
la terre
[Musique]
ce sera toi qui s'étend maintenant à
clichy tafer sera poncé pas